there is a really weird Story coming out
of the
UK police are investigating the first
case of rape in the metaverse the
metaverse is just the video game world
that Mark Zuckerberg wants us all to
live in and you put on the goggles and
it's a totally immersive kind of video
game according to prosecutors a child a
girl under the age of 16 was attacked in
a virtual reality video game and she was
left distraught after her Avatar was G
raped by strangers
online now the report goes on to make
clear that the girl did not suffer any
physical injuries obviously she was just
wearing a headset in a video game but
prosecutors say she suffered emotional
injuries and they're going to
investigate this as some kind of sexual
crime and a lot of conservatives are
making fun of this they're saying are
you kidding me she should have just
taken the headset off are you kidding me
it's just a video game grow up are you
kidding me she doesn't have any physical
injuries so it's there's no crime took
place
to which I
say that's the most liberal take I've
ever heard are you kidding me of you you
think that the only kind of crime that
can take place is a physical crime you
think that what we do
online is is morally neutral that we
shouldn't be held accountable for what
we do on are you kidding that's what the
libs think that's not what the
conservatives think absolutely these
guys should be
investigated I'm not saying it's
identical to
rape but it's not totally similar why is
rape bad rape why why is rape a a more
serious crime than any other kind of
physical assault if if rape were just
about the body if if if uh human life
were just about the physical then a
sexual assault would be no different
from any other kind of assault right the
reason it's so much worse is because
we're not just bodies we're Souls we
have psyches we have emotions we have
souls we value things like integ and
modesty and virtue and a a a a violation
a sexual violation is more severe it
cuts more deeply at the human person
than if someone just came up and punched
you in the face or cut you on the
wrist we're talking about a little girl
here you know if if these guys were just
discovered to have texted inappropriate
messages to a let's say I don't know how
old a girl is but let's say she's 12 or
13 if if these guys were found to have
texted in inap sexual messages at her I
think everyone would agree they should
be investigated and probably
prosecuted so why is it any different if
it happens in a video game where instead
of texting words instead of the symbols
being letters and words the symbols are
characters enacting all of these gross
obscene things on the Avatar of a little
girl the reason I think this is
important is there is a view that has
prevailed on the left and on the right
that whatever
the law says in the in the physical
world in the real
world we shouldn't be held accountable
for anything we do
online online is just the wild west do
whatever you want that's a that's a bad
situation that has allowed all sorts of
terrible things to proliferate lots of
online crimes uh obviously the the now
ubiquity of
pornography you know sexual acts that
you would would never tolerate in the
real physical world everyone is allowed
to indulge in and encouraged to indulge
in online all the time uh Vicious Kind
of speech to one another vicious often
threatening sometimes illegal speech we
just encourage that you would never talk
to someone in real life the way you talk
to someone on
Twitter online it doesn't
matter I think anything that that allows
us to recognize that what we do
online is real is is a very good thing
and I think the girl probably is
somewhat scarred maybe not quite as much
as if she were attacked in the physical
world but totally immersive virtual
reality is a pretty close simulacrum
especially for people who aren't fully
developed go investigate these guys at I
mean there's also this question why was
she even playing the video game in the
first place where were her parents who
did these guys know she was a kid maybe
not you're just talking about little
avatar characters but
nevertheless investigate this put put
some guard rails on this if if someone
is living in the metaverse for let's say
an hour a day two hours a day four or
five hours a day and they're behaving
like a total Sater criminal psychosexual
stist and then they take off the goggles
and they go out to the real world our
modern liberal culture says well we can
easily compartmentalize those things but
any serious study of human nature says
no you can't because you're crafting
your very desires your behaviors your
your way of viewing the world your way
of viewing women your way of viewing
people your way viewing yourself in the
world you're crafting all of that with
how you spend your time how you
fantasize how you engage even if it's in
virtual
reality and that you're not going to be
able to just totally cut that off once
you re-enter into the real the so-called
real world I'm beginning to think the
the conservatives that you know the
church ladies they were totally right
about violent video games in the 90s
they were just a little too soon because
in the 90s you're talking about Mortal
Kombat everyone knows that's not reality
well now when you throw on the metaverse
goggles the line between reality and
video games is a lot blurrier and it can
do uh play a lot more tricks on your
psyche and your emotions and your
desires as we see here from the way this
girl I think rightly claims to be
victimized Chris Christie who is saying
he will not vote for Donald Trump if
he's the nominee if it's Biden versus
Trump in the fall would you vote for
Donald Trump no so what is it about
various Republican candidates for the
presidency who live with the knowledge
of what Trump has done to the country
the damage that he's done to this
country that will ensue for God knows
how long what is it about them that
causes them to just knee-jerk reaction
oh yeah I'd vote for Trump anyway it's
it's an interesting combination of two
emotions uh Mike fear and ambition so
the fear part of it is that all of them
treasure um their titles and so they
treasure their titles more than they
treasure the honor that's given to them
by the people to actually have those
titles and they don't want to lose them
and they're all worried about being
married by someone who would have Donald
Trump's endorsement that's a yeah yeah
no one's ever accused Chris Christie of
ambition or be the guy who worked for
Donald Trump after saying you know he's
a bad guy now he's a good guy now I hate
him again because Trump pushed him out
would you vote for him in the fall
no but of
course the primary condition for being
considered to to debate in the
Republican primary debates was a pledge
to say that you will support the
eventual nominee of the party and you
remember Donald Trump said I don't think
I'm going to sign that H and and there
was this big halo Donald Trump he has no
loyalty to anyone but himself he's
destroying the Republican Party he's
just got unbridled ambition he's unored
from any principle he doesn't he's uh
hey you know what Trump was honest about
that all the rest of the candidates
signed it including Chris Christie and
then what happens Chris Chris campaign
totally
collapses all of their campaigns
collapse other than Trump's which
remains strong and Chris they say okay
are you going to honor your pledge goes
no no I'm not no I'm a liar I'm an
ambitious liar and everything that we
accuse Donald Trump of we are all guilty
of to to the 10th degree yeah no no
way it reveals these
guys to lack the what was supposed to be
the distinguish in feature between them
and Trump which was Integrity principle
care for the party ideological Mooring
and something solid but they don't have
that especially not Chris Christie
perhaps it's unfair to to say the same
about the other candidates certainly not
Chris Christie who was supposed to be
the chief Trump
antagonist anything anything you could
say about Donald Trump
any accusation that you could make
against him any insult you could throw
his way applies 100 times to Chris
Christie so it doesn't work so the
holier than thou campaign the
sanctimonious Campaign which is in part
why that that line that word that
nickname for Ronda santis while it might
not have been
fair for DeSantis himself and while it
might not have uh been the easiest to
roll off the tongue it's why it was a a
good choice of words to use against
Trump opponents broadly is because that
has been the chief
tool for the anti-trump campaigns going
back to 2016 the
sanctimony well this Trump he's a
Ruffian he's so immoral he's so terrible
he's so this that but consistently along
the way that's true of on the Republican
side and the Democrat side consistently
along the way we found out that Trump's
opponents don't don't often seem to
demonstrate much more principle than
than he has himself often they
demonstrate far less man what a great
clip that was now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls YouTube
channel we'll see you next time